what we see about you to do videos
together where there's something really
disastrous happening and well this one's
good isn't it there's a new bug it's a
good one yeah it's my favorite favorite
kind of bug which is a security issue
and also it involves image file formats
that's my favorite kind of bug and you
can almost say it's not a bug at all
so the problem that we're looking at
today has been termed acropolypse and it
involves the PNG file for it but really
it's sort of we can expand it a bit to
actually think about how people create
files in particular when you've got an
existing file and you want to update it
um how do you actually do that in a way
that's secure and in this case doesn't
leave all the old data lying around for
people to find Mike do you want to sort
of talk us through it yeah some
researchers
um Simon Aarons and David Buchanan have
found this essentially proof of concept
that initially on Pixel phones
when you take a screenshot which we we
all do a lot so you go you go into a
phone you go screenshot and then maybe
you crop it to the bit you're interested
in or indeed to hide something you're
not interested in just bought something
on eBay and you want to make sure that
people don't see your address how much
you've paid for it that sort of thing
yeah yeah so you cut the image down you
send it off on whatever messaging app or
you put on Discord or whatever it is
you're using what's happened is on a
pixel phone when they write the new
screenshot this cropped screenshot over
the original file to send out they don't
delete the original file data when you
first captured a screenshot it's saved
onto the phone's disk you then crop it
down because you don't want all the
image to be shown and it saves over that
same file but it leaves quite a lot of
the original data intact now what it
should do of course is delete most of
the original data or indeed all of the
original data and have only the small
image which is what we wanted to send
out but that isn't what's happening but
that probably depends on how you save it
because obviously if you save a copy of
the file then you're going to be
generating a new one because you've got
the original as well probably need to
test that do we know any victim with a
pixel phone Sean so perhaps we'll have a
quick look and so you can roughly see
how a PNG file is structured and then
and why this has caused the problem so
it's probably worth saying while Mike's
getting ready that a PNG file exists
because you I mean there's two main file
formats that are used for images on the
web sort of not Vector images but so
bitmap images you've got jpeg which is
good for sort of real images photographs
and things and PNG which is good for
synthetic images because you can
compress them really well without losing
any quality if you try to use jpeg for
that sort of image you'll end up with
artifacts if you try to use PNG for real
world images they wouldn't compress that
well so it's probably worth the same
amount so actually this bug is kind of
simple when you look at it so when you
have a PNG file which is your original
screenshot that's been saved on the disk
and this is going to have at the top a
header
all right but it's going to have all
your pixel data right and then at the
bottom it's going to have what we call
an eye end block a chunk and this end
says to the thing that's reading the PNG
file there is no more PNG file stop
reading there and one of the nice things
about having this high-end Chunk on the
end is that then if you accidentally
have other data it gets ignored and you
don't have a situation where you're
showing weird bits of image underneath
and more artifacts right so it's sort of
robustness now what's happened is the
app has gone in cropped the image down
to a much smaller one which takes up
less space in memory
and then overwritten it onto this file
but it's left the rest of this file
intact because it's not truncated the
file so if I take a different color
which is our new cropped image we have a
header
at the top and the file sort of takes up
let's say this much room and it has
another eye end
here like this so this is our new image
saved over our old image and you can see
that quite a lot of the old image is
still here
so how do we get it well what David
Buchanan has done is he's written a
proof of concept that gets rid of this
new image that we already know because
we can see it and then tries to go from
here and reconstruct the PNG without the
original header which is very difficult
to do and presumably we need to know
some information about the actual image
of star we think like the width and
height otherwise we've got there are
ways to estimate you know what kind of
Dimensions the thing had but of course a
much easier way is to know the model of
phone that had the bug because they
capture a specific resolution so you put
in your model of phone and then you know
that the image is this wide and this
high and then we can drop down through
these different rows of data until we
get to the second I end which shouldn't
ever be there and reconstruct the image
it doesn't work perfectly because
this is also compressed right PNG has
various and compression mechanisms so
they have row level filters but first of
all try and make each row take up less
memory they then have LZ and Huffman
trees that also encode the data and so
the top here we did a computer file on
that we've actually done that many many
years ago they've done great videos on
LZ and Huffman encoding and so
essentially what your process here is we
don't necessarily have the initial
compressed data so maybe we're missing a
Huffman tree or something like this we
have to find one and then we can
compress decompress from this point and
you may still get artifacts because LZ
compression likes to look back at
previous data and maybe that data has
been overwritten so for a while you'll
get some nonsense and some issues with
PNG filters and then suddenly enough
data will be there but it all starts to
turn out okay and lots of your image
turns back up what you might find then
is that we send a message that's been
cropped and then you can uncrop it and
recover all the other messages that have
been sent from phone as well oh so this
is like when I told you we were filming
on Friday that's the one yeah I think
I'm gonna have to have words with Mike
after this is I think now at this point
Steve maybe a good thing to talk about
is wider this bit wasn't deleted right
yeah sorry I mean I think actually
before we get there one thing to that
really helps with this is that the PNG
file format breaks things down into 16
kilobyte chunks and if you think about
the amount of data that's in a modern
pixel phones image very quickly you're
going to start a new 16k chunk and then
all the compression is going to start
again and so you then got a point where
you can get the data if you know the
width and height when we send these
things out over Twitter Facebook other
messaging systems are available in
general
they will re-encode the file they'll do
some sort of filtering on it because
these files not only contain the image
they often contain What's called the
exif data which contains things like
what make of camera with this taken with
when was it taken the GPS coordinates of
when it was taken and thankfully
Facebook and Twitter have realized that
that's probably not data that you want
to be publicly available if I have a
really expensive nice new camera and
it's this exact location if you want to
come and steal it and I'm now just
posted that I'm on holiday
Etc I mean it's worth mentioning the
reason that this hasn't flagged up is
that when the PNG file format was
created back in the mid 90s it wasn't
uncommon and other file formats and
other programs that will cope with this
extra data to get on the beginning or
the end which is why you've got that
specific high-end header so that they
will ignore what's coming afterwards so
actually it is generating a perfectly
valid PNG because if you look at the
spec it doesn't say anything about
ignoring data or processing data that
comes after it we've reached the end of
the file it says it's the end of the
file we don't anything else so this is
why I said you might want to class it as
a book because actually it's generating
a perfectly valid PNG of course it's a
really nasty problem from a security
point of view because we're sending a
file which we think we've cropped out
useful information or information you
didn't want me to see but actually it's
still there and so I can load it into
David's tool or Simon's tool and see
what you're saying about me behind my
back yep that's right the I mean this is
the point I suppose is that PNG has been
very good at hiding this problem for
many years suppose I had a text document
and I accidentally wrote over the top
half and not the bottom half and didn't
delete the bottom half it would be very
obvious because you read your document
and you'd say well okay there's a whole
another half a document here that
shouldn't be there I need to fix a bug
in my code but it's written out this
file in the wrong way PNG has the exact
same problem but because of its eye-end
header no one's ever noticed it or at
least no one's noticed it for a few
years at least that we know of it's as
far as we know the first person to
discover it is Simon Evans who was
sending a file and just wait notice wait
a minute I just cropped this file and it
hasn't changed size still five megabytes
long but it's only sort of 16 pixels by
16 pixels or whatever it was that it got
yeah why is that still five megabytes of
course you then start investigating uh
and you suddenly find oh dear when
you're writing software and you've got a
file that you want to update you have to
specify how you want to open that so you
could open it for reading in which case
you can read data from it you can open
it for writing and you can open it for
read and write at the same time
simplifying things if you open it for
writing though
waiting on that data to go you could
have it so it's always appended to the
end of the file
you could have it so it overwrites
what's currently in that file or you
could say I want to actually completely
obliterate or truncate what's already in
that file and then just rewrite things
over this as if it was a completely
blank file and what seems to have
happened here particularly with the
issue on Pixel phones is that
the default has changed I think it was
in Android 10 or Android 11 they default
the default change from being you
truncated to being overrode don't scare
people too much but there's quite a
possibility there's other programs that
are doing this because this default has
changed I don't think this will be the
end of this I think we'll see similar
things it's no it's fascinating actually
because we should note that basically
what happened was this was noticed in
pixel phones the proof of concept came
out and then almost immediately someone
was messing around with other pngs from
the window Snipping Tool and found the
exact same totally different cause
totally different operating system same
bug right it's almost impossible this
doesn't exist and in some cases it's
actually by Design there are file
formats uh PDF documents that spring to
mind where you actually can update the
document by appending something to the
end of it and that appending can say for
example only show pages one two three
and five this isn't a new problem this
has been seen before but I think the big
problem here is that we have assumptions
about what happens when we crop
something the question now really is
what what do we do about it right now so
what's happened in the short term is
that Google have rolling out patches
down
very very quickly so good job for them
and the um authors of the bug so David
and Simon have um I've always been
publicizing this now some people have
said well you know is it is it a safe
thing to release a proof of concept all
but actually this is a really
interesting kind of bug because in some
sense patching it just stops it from
being a problem in the future yeah
you've already got five years of images
that could possibly be uncropped with
hidden data in just on the internet now
on people's hard drives other people's
phones we don't know where they are this
data it still exists and and actually I
mean it's worth saying we mentioned it
on people's hard drives on the state
when you even if this did it properly
for whatever better way of putting it
you'd probably find that if you had
physical access to the holidays you
could do exactly the same thing because
when you create a new file the old data
isn't necessarily overwritten it's just
marked as unused and it's only when the
trim is run on SSD or something
overwrites it on a hard disk that that
data gets obliterated and the
unfortunate thing is unless we develop
tools that iterate over all the images
let's say on all the images on a Discord
server or all the images I'm looking for
Wint and even that is potentially
because it's not infeasible that iend
could appear as a value compressed data
in the within the image yeah it's going
to be very interesting going forward so
I think in the short term you know the
patches are coming out it means that
from now on when you crop an image down
it's actually going to get cropped and
saved that way on a disk but you know if
you've saved a lot of images across the
internet and they've not necessarily
been re-encoded and it's never quite
clear who's re-encoding and who is just
sending the image I suspect messaging
tools will probably do it with images
but not with files because they're
probably sending images in a slightly
different way we know what for example
we're in codes but if you had a zip of
files yeah it's not going to be it's not
going to be encodable images within that
zip almost certainly not it's just going
to send a zip file Simon one of the
authors is working on a tool now that
will hopefully iterate over images and
tell people whether or not this bug
exists for them yep some people will do
that some people won't and we'll we'll
have to see how it goes are we calling
this uh crop lips now Acropolis now for
sure and then we can be we'll and we'll
pose for them what was the sort of pose
on the movie poster sort of a and then
you can make me red yeah
for it and release it yourself so
um there are two Primitives here one's
called malloc and malloc says give me
some quantity of